[Music]
it's no secret that for better or for
worse
nothing makes the world of cs go spin
like a skin
amidst a sea of psy-inducing scent on
the dollar blues there shines an elite
crew of highly coveted statement pieces
classic iconic costly show stoppers
that'll help you stomp the server in
style he needs a multi-kill first found
twist aggressing they have to double
peek he's getting his shots he's hitting
another one simple
that's unbelievable but no matter how
flashy and sophisticated said showpieces
get
none will ever supersede or even be as
sought after as the bolt action beast
that started it all it could be really
rough for symbol to actually get through
this he's gonna throw the awp oh my god
[Applause]
this is the story of the cs go cosmetic
to end all cs go cosmetics the ultra
rare offering that when you think about
it essentially shaped the world of skin
trading gambling and scamming into the
withering wild west it is today
[Music]
this is the story of the dragon lore
[Music]
okay so in order to understand why the d
lore was such a seminal addition to
counter-strike cosmetics we first need
to understand why it is that cosmetics
were such a seminal addition to
counter-strike launched as part of the
arms deal update in august of 2013 one
year after cs go's initial launch the
introduction of weapon skins wasn't just
seen as a way to spice up this fabled
fps but to support it as it entered a
new age so this takes the good aspects
of tf2 you know the whole first person
shooter style of monetizing it and it
also takes the parts of dota 2 where
they've learned how to do an esport and
it also introduces some cool new stuff
you know knives and weapon skins and
that's right you get skins on your
weapon you can paint on it it looks
green or look red or blue aside from
earning a valve a ton of revenue
cosmetic sales crowd-sourced funds for
cs go's blossoming esports scene and
eventually the influx of artists who
like in valve's other self-published
titles dota 2 and team fortress 2 took
their talents to the steam workshop the
skins update was a big change for the
community giving you something you can
buy something that you can customize
your guns it's done where it doesn't
necessarily impact gameplay but it gives
people this exciting element to keep
coming back and keep playing to get more
skins of course what made these
infrastructures so interesting back in
the early to mid 2010s before
microtransactions became what they are
today is how haphazard and experimental
they were we decided that cs go would
become our first game
in which every item can be placed on the
marketplace
and individual items can't be bought any
other way
in fact the only thing that we planned
to sell directly were the keys used to
open our case drops as revealed during a
talk at the 2014 game developers
conference valve knew that adding skin
economies to their ips could be huge
they just didn't know what those
economies should look like or the skins
for that matter at this point we were
getting actually really concerned
because how many different camouflaged
weapons can we make that people are
really going to care about
but as we got further along gathering
reference we discovered that there's a
whole world out there we weren't even
aware of people make crazy things for
their weapons everything from uh
intricate victorian scroll work right up
to straight up graffiti unsurprisingly
perhaps cs go's initial cosmetic
offerings weren't especially imaginative
since valve wasn't actually sure what
the community would gravitate towards
bright neon looking numbers or drab
realistic camos they slapped together
safe lo-fi offerings in the interest of
seeing what would stick the higher tier
of the esports 2013 stuff like the old
boom was actually a little wild but if
you look at the weapon case one i think
that was their general impression of
what was going to succeed of course they
did stick but in a way that was by
today's standards at least somewhat tame
obviously back then
there wasn't the same interest in skins
that wasn't the same economy in the
market as there is today like back then
there wasn't much money online in
general that people had their pocket
money that they would spend or like a 10
steam card and that would get you an ak
and up and maybe like your whole loadout
for 10 15 bucks minus the the knife of
course you know speaking of knives none
of this is to say that the early days of
cs go skins didn't yield their own array
of elite offerings opening cases is just
as expensive awful and exhilarating now
as it was back then
no way you didn't just open that [ __ ] i
think that's what sets apart cs go skins
from tf2 skins and you know other skins
is that there's such complexity to csgo
skins that tf2 skins or other games
don't have you know and yet in spite of
the unprecedented depth sophistication
and rarity of such offerings the market
was still nascent people still looked at
skins as
well just that play things back in the
early times a lot of stuff was done on
the steam market there wasn't really any
third-party websites
and that was kind of limited to back
then the steam max was around 400 i
believe and then late in the summer of
2014 cs go saw the release of operation
breakout and with it three newly themed
weapon collections baggage
overpass
and cobblestone and in the last of those
crowning the top sat a covert that would
change cs go skins
forever when the d-lord landed it was it
was just just the first of its kind
wasn't it it was nothing like the
community he had ever seen before and
unfortunately i had a price tag to
follow within a matter of months this
exquisite ornate and
unprecedentedly unattainable op had
caught the community's attention like no
cosmetic ever had just in terms of like
the aesthetics of the skin it was the
first one that people looked at and just
thought wow the amount of detail and
attention that has gone into the skin
and just the overall look of it and the
dragon you know like amazing i would
definitely agree that it was the first
skin that had that status of like shock
factor like almost like a a lamborghini
in in real life you know it was that
first thing that's like everyone's like
oh my god this guy on the team has a
dragon lord one of the reasons for this
of course is that by the time 2015 was
underway a certain cracked out of his
mind oper was not only cementing himself
as the nuttiest player alive but
conducting quick scope oriented
pyrotechnics the likes of which the
world had never seen they need to go big
and kenny's gonna go ahead and peek in a
second minute he gets the flick on his
lightning fast he doesn't have like any
time to work with the bomb plans can
take five seconds alone he's gonna go
for it behind the fountain carrick just
gonna charge him down he's gonna miss
quite a few pistol shots kenny yeah what
a kill kerrigan should not have but then
he counts the second kds clutches around
not only did kenny s cause opting to
explode in popularity but certain ops in
particular namely the signature fabled
frag utensils that were his asimov and
eventually dragon lore both of which he
cheekily dubbed his magic stick he's
inside of this monk he's trying to play
clever with this awp and he's got one no
no way kenny you gotta stop
take it away from him there's no way to
shut him down up close today well this
is where he's going
he just doesn't stop he's not letting up
the pressure is being applied and
astralis cannot deal with kenny s it's a
match made in heaven isn't it like
everyone watching him is going to want
to be like him and one of the best ways
to just stunt out and be like him is
going to be with the dragon law everyone
and their mother wanted a delor but
because it was an operation drop it was
really rare only available for a limited
time and since it was extremely sought
after
bought off the market almost instantly
securing one basically became the single
biggest flex in counter-strike please
[Music]
well almost the biggest flex oh my gosh
oh my gosh
oh my gosh
to this day there is no more esteemed
pull in the whole of counter-strike than
a souvenir dragon lore like the skin
itself the act is a thing of legend a
feat so probabilistically unlikely that
to achieve it is in essence to do the
impossible to etch oneself into cs go
skin history
i had already opened so many of them and
i already knew the chances were so
incredibly slim and i got nothing but
purples so as soon as i saw that dragon
lore just a roll into the screen and
actually land i just couldn't believe it
but honestly it didn't matter whether
your d-lore was souvenir or straight up
spotless or scuffed as [ __ ] the skin was
such a showpiece held so much cultural
clout that to own any iteration of it
made you feel like you were on top of
the world nitro does have a box of
another smoke so it could be really
rough or simple to actually get through
this he's going to throw the awp oh my
god simple
[Applause]
the issue of course is that soon after
the skin started to become absurdly
iconic so too did it start to become
absurdly scarce i mean what what
actually happened is that they just
became hoarded right so you would have
the the big big big bots of of of
trading sites they would use that as
sort of like
their bankroll so you would fill an
inventory with house medusas and delores
and then get them banned by valve later
on so that's sort of like how the the
supply diminished as well was because of
people
using the dealer as literal currency
whether you were into trading sites
gambling sites building a collection for
the ages or simply scamming people the
dragon lore became the go-to coinage and
collateral of any and all counter-strike
related dealings illicit or otherwise
coupled with the fact that cobblestone
was removed from the active duty map
pool about midway through 2018 removing
the possibility for new souvenir drops
and the fact that csgo went two years
without an operation the dragon lore
went from scarce to all but extinct
where have the dragon laws gone because
it's been about 18 months since our last
dropping during operation hydra and over
12 months since the last major the
e-league boston which had souvenir
cobblestone package drops which is a bit
weird considering the dragon law is one
of the most iconic and valuable skins in
cs go just the structure of the
whole skins itself
it kind of ensures its rarity and the
fact that obviously they're not well to
my knowledge they're not getting put
back into the game anytime soon and then
a huge new player who'd entered the
market about a year and a half prior
started to get serious about
counter-strike in a way that really
upped the player base and by extension
skin prices
like never before
china they shifted this entire thing of
just hoarding d-lords into
everyone needed it it's a starter kit
it's a rich
player starter kit so if you wanted to
become a respectable collector you
needed a factory new dragon lore you
need a blue gem you need a sapphire
knife you need a hull and and you need
some factory new gloves or something
like that as far as orps go there is no
debating that this thing is number one
and not just because it's expensive but
because it's seen as a sign of how
wealthy you are if you reach you buy a
dragon law if you want to prove you're
really really rich you buy 10 dragon
laws this is how you demonstrate to
people that you have money within no
time the dragon lore went from this
high-end luxury showpiece to an
essential indispensable status symbol an
unmistakably iconic instantly
recognizable must-have for any and every
wealthy trader who wanted to flex on the
have-nots but nowadays i've experienced
this personally this is a funny story a
chinese collector goes into a game meets
another chinese collector
he has a field tested no actually he has
a minimal wear dragon lure and the guy
is like
don't you have a faction new dragon lore
are you poor
he
buys a factory new dragon lore in game
to settle that with the other guy
because when all is said and done the
dragon lore isn't just a skin it's the
skin the one that everyone recognizes
across every era sector and skill
echelon of cs go wait wait wait wait he
has a dragon lore
what the hell this dude's inventory is
nuts did he get mass reported because
he's got such a nice inventory it
doesn't matter how many pretenders to
the throne might emerge and how shiny
sophisticated and genuinely sought after
they might be there is nothing as clean
as classic as timeless and emblematic of
the esport it helped evolve
as a dragon lore ewp drops home as well
that means they have to recommit good
find therefore for lucas
still an all-important round and a
massive frag
from pasha
gave them a lifeline in the first half
this time he may give them more than
that because he finds it third what a
game device who's had a really rough
game flashed he's gonna get that shot
and it has to feel a little bit good out
middle of the air to take down alex and
now they're pushing oh
takes every single one
from nothing to the awps
modesty on catwalk finds the timing
eight seconds if he can drop the bomb
it'd be everything but it travels into
the site one on two from odyssey now
it's sacrificial gives his position away
he wants bonuses
[Applause]
takes down the goat
blue gems all of them go hard but none
of them can capture the attention of a
counter-striker like a lore oh my god no
way i got a dragon lore i got a dragon
lore please
i actually got one the dragon lore is in
no one certain terms the one true king
of cs go skins through thick and thin it
has stood atop the world of
counter-strike and it's safe to say that
for as long as there are skins to trade
it always will
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring the notification bell for unique
bite size videos you won't find anywhere
else hit us up on our twitter instagram
facebook and tech talk